oreos tweeted out yesterday quote
trans people exist
my first reaction to oreo's bold
statement here was
you are a cookie why
why am i listening to the uh
philosophical declarations
why why am i listening to the gnostic
dualist theories of a delicious sandwich
cookie
i don't know because we're living in a
very very
stupid time where everything has to be
politicized you know this
was i i hate as you know to keep
plugging my book
but providentially my book happens to be
about all this stuff that's going on
like right this very minute and this was
the plan of the the people who pushed
political correctness
it was to politicize all of the terms
all of the things beginning with in karl
marx's words the ruthless criticism of
all that exists
which develops then into critical theory
which you see a lot on college campuses
now we've heard a lot about critical
race theory
into the feminists of the 1970s who said
that the personal is the political every
intimate interaction between
everybody everything your cookies your
coffee mugs your sneakers
your relationship to your husband or
wife everything has to be open to public
scrutiny now
and politicized including oreos
including
mr potato head and mrs potato head so
now oreo cookie when you eat the oreo
cookie you were making
a political statement if you enjoyed
that video be sure to hit the subscribe
button so everyone waiting through the
wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there